hello and welcome to another edition of
The Gadget Lab show I'm Christina
Bonnington and I am Roberto Baldwin
today we've got the nuke HD to show you
and we'll take a look at the latest
Google and Android news and then we've
got to give away so don't go anywhere
you're gonna get free stuff well one
person is gonna get free stuff maybe
even two maybe two people hmm so what do
you have to show us today Robbie I have
the nook HD now this is the 7-inch
tablet from barnes & noble it's a it's a
nice tablet you know it goes right up
against the kindle fire HD oh and what's
nice about this tablet is that it has
profiles so you can set up profiles for
yourself if you have kids you can set up
a profile to keep your kids from getting
on the internet and you know buying
random stuff are going to you know scary
websites cool yeah tablets are a lot of
times just used in family and the home
so there's a few different people with
different preferences yeah so you know
and you know you just grab your poop and
it goes to your your profile it's pretty
it has the apps that you want some of
how you want it where you want them it's
pretty cool and it and it's shipping
with this now I know amazon has one it's
just it allows you to make a profile for
kids but this is ready now you can get
it it's two hundred bucks for eight
gigabytes it's 230 for 16 gigabytes my
biggest issue with this tablet really is
this plastic like edge it feels super
super cheap and it's kind of like he can
make a noise it's it's not it's not
awesome that's probably one of my
favorite things about the ipad mini when
it comes to the 78 inch space to build
quality is so nice compared to some of
these other 7-inch tablets but if you so
much pricier yeah yeah it's it's a
pricey it's much prized I mean the 200
bucks yeah it's it's a good little
tablet I like it a how a full review
came up on the gadget lab but this thing
is it drives me nuts because it is a
really good tablet and
if you're in the the barnes noble
ecosystem you should really check this
out
Nate's here and what do you have for us
today I have one of the largest
smartphones I think maybe ever made it's
called the samsung galaxy note 2 as a
5.5 inch display it's gigantic it is
gigantic yes you can it's the size of my
face pretty much it's pretty much as big
as your face which is kind of yeah yeah
maybe maybe a smaller face but even
that's a have a pretty decent sized head
and it's a big it's a big it's a big
phone it's yes it's huge yeah how to
display the display is gorgeous we have
a 1280 by 720 display here it's
beautiful it doesn't look the greatest
in direct sunlight but it still does
look really really great now Samsung's
displays are a little bit amped up on
the colors just a little oversaturated
but I mean it's it's beautiful it's kind
of nice you really I don't know I only
noticed it on photos yeah for like
animations and images and stuff yeah it
totally looks good everything pops you
know in a slightly unnatural way but
it's very pleasing yeah now it's a super
fast phone we have a 1.6 gigahertz
samsung quad-core processor in hearing I
think this is Samsung's first quad-core
phone for the u.s. they try to do that
with the galaxy s3 but with LTE and you
know sucking battery life and stuff they
opted for a dual-core processor which
was honestly just as great but here you
got a quad core processor 2 gigs of ram
and it's going to sell for about 300
bucks on five different carriers this
probably the coolest part is you can get
this phone on AT&T Sprint Verizon
t-mobile and US cellular it's basically
the exact same phone there's slight
differences in the radios they have for
their LTE networks but it's basically
the same phone on five different
carriers and one of the cool things is
like you're not seeing like a ridiculous
logo here for those carriers so it's
basically the same exact phone really
only Apple has been able to pull it off
with the iphone so it's kind of a unique
design thing that I really appreciate
yeah and that's a huge roll out to five
carriers major rollout yeah yeah it's
pretty much hitting carriers right now
working on the review of it and you know
this is not necessarily a screen size I
would want to live with every day I
think it's too big for me but you know
if you're looking for
something gigantic like this and if you
don't mind having like a stylist yeah
the S Pen Stylus from Samsung so you can
like you know draw on the screen and you
can mark up photos and you can do all
kinds of stuff then this might be
something you're into what do you think
of the S Pen Stylus you know it's a
really nice stylus but it's not as as
accurate as detailed as maybe like you
know graphic designer reviews on it like
you know wacom tablet or some like that
but it's not bad i mean for sketching
out a little stuff it's fine i was
drawing before the Georgetown Hoya
mascot it looks like fun it's not bad on
previous stuff of I've done some more
detailed things and it's cool like if
you're just try and drop them down it
works but is it better than just using
your finger on any other phone not
really i don't see like massive massive
utility here it's not going to change
your life cool it's just something
hopefully you don't lose em and we have
a product giveaway today we have two
iphone 5 cases from spec one of them has
a space where you can put your cards so
you don't have to carry your wallet with
you can just stick a few your ID and
fancy card in here and then this one is
not that it's just different it's kind
of a flexible case so if you want one of
these in the comments of the post what
is the difference in the diagonal screen
size between the galaxy note 2 and the
iphone 5 in inches whoever is first to
the first two people to get the correct
answer will get in touch with you and
mail you your iphone 5 case cool well
thanks for tuning in we'll see you next
week later